großes kino nicht oft weil können ja ich
bin sehr dafür dass der lehrer das macht
mir daheim völlig tami gehackt index
also in der schule haben das thema
praktisch mit kopf mit großer kälte sind
eigentlich möglich land
finnland ich bin doktor ruth westheimer
menschen hier fragen beantworten oder
klausuren zu beantworten
doch das ist eine frage wie krieg nicht
auf 6 ganzen welt es gibt frauen die
würden ganz gerne oralverkehr mit ihrem
mann machen möchten aber nicht dass er
so reagiert und das muss man eben sich
besprechen das kann man nicht einfach
fragen
[Musik]
sie schnitten besser ab als die frage
welcher auf sexualität ist nicht
zwischen dem gürtel und den knien das
ist im kopf also der untere teil des
körpers wahr ist muss mit dem kopf
gemacht werden wunderbare frage
[Musik]
diese frau hat millionen von menschen
aufgeklärt doktor ruf die 91-jährige ist
die sexberaterin schlechthin in den usa
oder ruth westheimer dank fernsehen und
radio zum star
von anfang an habe ich gesagt du
brauchst nie zu sagen ich hab ne frage
eine bekannte von mir ein bekannter von
mir ein verwandter ohne namen hab ne
frage
und das hat eingeschlagen war dann
niemand angst gehabt hat dass jemand die
sprache erkennt dass jemand sie am
television erkennt denn ich habe immer
gesagt es nicht wichtig wer fragt das
wichtige ist dass die fragen beantwortet
werden damit die leute mehr sexuell
wissen
[Applaus]
fernsehshows mit doktor ruf sind der
absolute straßenfeger bank of china der
typ zum audimax ort
die findet auch im schweizer fernsehen
spricht sie klartext über 6 es gibt
frauen wie brauchen zur vollen
befriedigung mehr wie einen orgasmus und
es macht aber nichts wenn sie den ersten
orgasmus während im geschlechtsverkehr
haben und dann kann der mann entweder
mit dem finger oder vielleicht mit der
großen zehe weiter befriedigen so lange
bis die frau allein das wort orgasmus
öffentlich auszusprechen ist damals
revolutionär
ruth westheimer kindheit ist geprägt
durch den terror der nazis in
deutschland als neunjähriges
flüchtlingskind kommt sie in die schweiz
nach heiden
in dieser zeit werden ihre jüdischen
eltern in auschwitz ermordet
[Musik]
nach dem krieg zieht es sie nach
palästina
später studiert sie in paris und den usa
psychologie
sie heiratet und hat zwei kinder
ein zufall dass sie das thema sex zu
ihrem beruf macht von meinem hintergrund
als länder als flüchtlingskind in die
schweiz 1939 dann bin ich weise geworden
die eltern und die ganze familie sind
umgekommen und 1 habe ich gewusst ich
muss etwas machen auf der welt um zu
zeigen warum ich überlebt ab ich habe
aber nicht gewusst dass das mit sex zu
tun haben wird kein mensch hat das sonst
gemacht aber ich habe einen doktor
doktorat an der columbia in der
psychologie von der familie und ich war
sehr gut trainiert und dann hab ich
gesehen da ist etwas wo ich einen
unterschied machen kann wo ich zeigen
kann dass man über diese sache sprechen
darf mit humor aber ohne es ins lachen
zu bringen wenn sie sagen vielleicht
haben sie noch keinen orgasmus gehabt
dann würde ich erst mal vorschlagen dass
sie selbst sich befriedigen
denn kein man auch kein schweizer auch
nicht der beste liebhaber kann eine frau
zum orgasmus bringen wenn die frau sich
nicht selbst die erlaubnis gibt dieses
gefühl zu erfüllen
das war unerhört zumal sexueller genuss
bislang ausschließlich der männlichen
geschlecht vorbehalten war
ob in der ehe oder außerhalb im bordell
frauen hingegen hatten keusch in die ehe
zu gehen
geschlechtsverkehr war für sie lediglich
zur reproduktion gedacht lust war für
frauen nicht vorgesehen
doch die westliche gesellschaft
veränderte sich grundlegend und damit
auch das sexuelle verhalten und zwar hat
das mit der industrialisierung stone
blüht sind vom land und stadt die junge
frauen und männer mit starker center
natürlich der schutz der familie und dem
sind kann man sagen ist sechs mal ob
gerade in der phase wie ihr es ist nicht
umgangen dass die jungen deswegen kurz
tour und informationen sondern viel mehr
mit angst hat dass sie aber ich glaube
dass sie zur prostituierten können dass
sie alle haben natürlich dass sie
schwanger werden wähle verhindere
bei ihrer recherche über sexuelle
aufklärung stellt sie fest dass nebst
der scham auch das darüber reden ein
problem darstellt der ausbruch ist
natürlich dann auch nicht nur das mit
öffentlichkeit sondern dass die zukunft
ältere das müsste man sich vorstellen
wenn über eine so lange zeit über das
thema twitter wo sind wir und das
plötzlich das mit der familie über das
rent oder quasi vater zum sohn oder
tochter
das ist ein risiko wandel und für die
eta hat mit löst das wird schwierig sie
und ähnliche ganze neue literaturgattung
entstanden nämlich es hätten ganz viel
gruseliger und die brasilien versucht
der eltern vermitteln wie man die
zeitlich müsste klar
erst nach dem zweiten weltkrieg wird in
den usa fundiert über sexuelle
essverhalten geforscht pionier war der
zoologe alfred kinsey um aufklären zu
können müsse man zuerst wissen was die
leute in ihrem schlafzimmer so treiben
tanten kind sie und sein team so kam es
zur ersten studie dieser art mit rund
20.000 testpersonen
[Musik]
für übermäßiges masturbieren zu
vorzeitiger ejakulation ist es
ungewöhnlich wenn mein freund meine
nanos berührt das sind alles
ausgezeichnete fragen und alle haben die
gleiche antwort ich weiß es nicht
die veröffentlichung der
studienergebnisse sogenannten kind
reports und schlugen ein wie eine bombe
was den usa ruhig und dass ich auch
nicht schockierend sie das quasi die
vorstellung womit die norm gar nicht
über die stumme hat mit seinem ergebnis
die forschungsresultate boten der
wissenschaft wertvolle grundlagen sind
sie selber wurde heftig kritisiert und
sogar vom fbi verfolgt eine erkenntnis
war dass das kirchliche onanie verbot
offenbar munter unterlaufen wurde für
pink sie respektive eigentlich hab mir
immer noch sagt das ist schädlich für
den körper und alle die zum sieg von
datalogic ja bis zu 70 prozent der
jugendlichen an ihren und das hat eine
neue realität zeigt ich hätte nie doktor
und west an die berühmte in hand
führungs zeichen werden können ohne kind
sie hasst es & johnson aber ich war
nicht so interessiert an diesen
untersuchungen mitzumachen
ich wollte nur dass die mir die
resultate geben von den untersuchungen
und das haben sie genau das haben sie
gemacht
die amerikanischen forschungsergebnisse
beeinflussen auch die schweiz in den
schulen über sex zu reden ist bis in die
60er jahre ein tabu sagte er es ein
lehrer im schwimmunterricht über sex zu
sprechen wurde über ihn im fernsehen
berichtet ja wobei mir der typ dieses
schwimmstunde zunächst über
selbstbefriedigung ja also ich hatte
wohl zunächst das wachstum wird manager
forum mit dem titel was immer klar seine
krankheiten von selber mein jahr das ist
typisch für den er denkt nur wenig dafür
dass sich aus branche des lebens von -
wie ich sage also in denen das nicht
einfach still um sie herum redet also
früher
damit trifft noch einen entscheide teil
ist bezeichnend auch beim
fortschrittlichen lehrer geht es bei den
buben um sexualität bei den mädchen in
erster linie und biologie
menschen
das haben die perioden die menstruation
so werden
[Musik]
zu hause sollten eltern ihre kinder
aufklären mussten aber selbst nicht
bescheid
das war die stunde von oswalt kolle in
der 1960 er jahren werden seine
aufklärungsbuch und filme für erwachsene
zum verkaufsschlager
[Musik]
ganz egal was ich der gefühle
na hör mal was vielleicht nicht schön
ich spüre nichts ich verstehe ich selber
nicht daran es bestimmt die pille schuld
ist du so sicher ja war ein anderen
mädchen hat es immer geklappt jedoch zu
den andern kino aufklärungsfilme sind in
der schweiz zwar beliebt in zürich
werden sie aber aus moralischen gründen
verboten
es wurde mir hinter tagen dass der
polizeipräsident von zürich gesagt hat
werden mit es wird verboten wir lassen
uns doch nicht von einem deutschen
erklären wie wir uns hier in bitten zu
verhalten haben
[Musik]
sie müssen sich die stimmung vorstellen
für junge leute heute dass einer der
zensoren gesagt hat herr kolle wollen
sie den die ganze welt auf den kopf
stellen jetzt soll sogar die frau schon
oben liegen wunderbar herr kohle bravo
weil dann die klitoris sehr viele pässe
berührt werden kann
[Musik]
schon als ich ja das war ich schon sehr
auf das thema sexualität gefallen sehr
früh die psychiatrie war immer die
reparatur anstalt für eine verkrüppelte
sexualität eine sexualität die durch die
gesellschaft durch die prüderie durch
eine gegenaufklärung die menschen kaputt
gemacht hat wunderbar
schade dass ich ihn nicht gekannt ab ich
bin sehr mit ihm einverstanden denn die
psychiatrie hat eine lange zeit
gebraucht bis sie anerkannt hat dass man
über sexualität auf und sprechen kann
umfragen in den 70er jahren zeigen die
kinder haben vielleicht eine ahnung von
sex aber praktisch kein wissen
wenig erstaunlich auch den eltern fehlt
das vokabular
[Musik]
weißt du wie kind ruft weil sie hinter
körper weiß nicht ob wir kunst in dem
buch
[Musik]
die einzige tochter
was ich heute guckt das ist klar sagt
sozusagen eins der hand ich heimlich
ganze show unveil was ja einfach
gebrochen
günther eines ewigkeit sind rekruten die
frage gar und bitteren 35 männer seid
gesegnet mit hofstaat wurden und
fertigen
das hat das hessische team sehen theorie
xiii und drum herum sind die dauernde
aufgabe übernahm natürlich nackte
broschüre wurden wieder entstanden sind
da irgendwie gesprungen ist als
informationsmaterialien
philipp für die neue norm für die
neuausrichtung aber dabei den sexuellen
aufklärung in der schule
anstatt gegen die wachsende sexualität
sinnlos zu predigen hat sich dieser
primarlehrer eine viel schwerere aufgabe
gestellt
mit in sein lehrprogramm einbezogen hat
er für buben und mädchen die sexuelle
aufklärung nicht als starres schulfach
von 9 bis 10 oder zwei bis drei uhr
sondern als zwanglosen bestandteil
seines erziehungs prinzips was bedeutet
dass sich anknüpfungspunkte zu solchen
gesprächen jederzeit ergeben können
[Musik]
1971 fiel das schweizer pornografie
verbot und nur wochen später eröffnete
der erste sexshop der schweiz
aufklärende literatur welche für den
laien verständliche sexual information
liefert bildet den schwerpunkt des
angebotes in dem laden dabei wird
unterschieden zwischen anfänger
literatur und aufklärung für
fortgeschrittene erotische inhalte
breiteten sich im öffentlichen raum
immer mehr aus nackte haut sogar am
kiosk und damit stieg die sorge um eine
mögliche sexualisierung der jugend und
genauso wie heute warnte man schon
damals auch die aller behüteten kinder
werden mit sexuellen darstellungen
konfrontiert den abbildungen von
erotischem inhalt begegnen uns heute
überall und jeder nur erdenklichen form
sexualität ist vorher als unterdrückte
instrument wagner wurde verändert hat
sich nicht da sitzt sexualität plötzlich
19 natur gehört sondern mich wieder
vorausgegangen wie musik einfach die
unterdrückung und der hund quasi wie die
natürliche sexualität für das ich so das
narrativ die erzählung von defizit und
dem sehen hätte das natürlich schon eine
starke liberalisiert geführt weil sie
hängt sexualität natürlich überhaupt
monate komplett sondern sich sexualität
als nur alibi oder so knüpft sie aber
die themse ist sexualität und lust
zügigen bereicherung für das individuum
für stasi dass ich ein ganz anderer
betrinken
die jugendzeitschrift bravo wird bis
1972 als jugendgefährdend eingestuft
dabei hat sich mehr als eine generation
genau dort ihr basiswissen über sechs
selbst angeeignet
dem team von doktor sommer sei dank
[Musik]
wenn ich quasi die alte normen eine
stimme
wir unterstützen mit den ist ihr kind
und junger damit sie können befrieden
die sexualität um es damals aber was
braucht setzt und die dem zimmer haben
ist quasi bietet noch sexuell auffällig
langsam akzeptiert die gesellschaft die
realität dass menschen sex vor der ehe
haben die traditionelle rollenverteilung
beim sex der mann ist aktiv die frau
passiv bleibt unangetastet
explizite aufklärungsfilme sind die
ausnahme das ist ein job in montreux sie
klassisches ganz tolles gefühl für baby
und vertraue ich gern in ihrer drin und
sex kann wenn sie in wieseck spürt dem
sieht man liebe machen bewegung fange
langsam aber das schnellere schneller
weil sie eben immer stärker stützen
der markt bewegt penis lawrow ihrer
vagina ufer und aber damit die kürzliche
stelle aneinander krawatte wetter und
frau so fest bedeckt hält
dass man verschmiert sie explodieren der
ich das obwohl das fehlen von japan geht
schließlich innere herren nach
wunderschönen explosion
und dann für die 80er jahre mit hiv aids
und gewalt thematik wird vieles thema
sexuelle ausbeutung und so weiter und
blätter und sexualität und das hat
natürlich noch luft und ruft sexualität
rückkopplungseffekt wie in den fast 100
jahren zuvor geht es in der
sexualaufklärung in der 1980 er jahren
um gefährliche folgen von 6 diesmal ist
das hiv die sexuell übertragbare
krankheit aids die wissenschaft uns
glaubhaft versichert sind präservative
vorläufig das einzig wirksame mittel um
sich vor einer ansteckung mit dem aids
virus zu schützen
dieses kleine ding kann also über leben
und tod entscheiden daran ändern weder
erotische noch ist ethische oder
moralische bedenken etwas tagesschau
moderator schalk lehrzeit zur
hauptsendezeit ein präservativ
angesichts der großen angst vor aids
wird etwas möglich was undenkbar schien
aufklärungskampagnen werden über die
jahre dem sexualverhalten angepasst
trotz drohung dass man partner wechselt
safer sex bleibt und das nimmt der free
tv hits oder auch sehr realistisch aus
mehr besetzung gespielt dass die
durchschnittliche person sechs pcs
ex-partner offset wechseln die wie er
der fünfte person sind es über 20 also
sicher botschaft wo viele mythologische
bescheid wissen wie man sich schützen
kann
in diesem teil der sexuellen aufklärung
investieren bund und kantone bis heute
das krankheit da war es noch wichtiger
dass jemand wie ich so homosexuellen
gesprochen habe wie auf wie sie
aufpassen müssen
kondome benutzen wie wichtig es ist
einen partner zu haben
nicht jede nacht mit dem anderen ins
bett und so habe ich eine ganze karriere
aufgebaut
in den 80er jahren bekommt auch die
schweiz eine prominent des ex beraterin
marta am neckar besser bekannt als liebe
macht taub
ich habe schnell den erklärt wir
natürlich studiert haben und mit
fachleuten fachlich informiert haben
dass es nicht als persönliches problem
gibt zwar nicht irgendwie asexualität
berührt oder btx ist das sexuelle
probleme immer mit der ganzen über die
liebesgeschichte mit der persönlichkeit
wird der mensch zweimal also das hat
mich danach seine unglücks ziehen ihren
die blick sex-kolumnistin beantwortet
täglich intimste sechs fragen der
leserschaft und wird so zur aufklärerin
der nation treffen martha und dr ruf im
fernsehen aufeinander sind gute
einschaltquoten garantiert eine ganz
besondere überraschung
ich hab hier nicht nur ein fantastisches
publikum
ich hab im marita hier mit mir ein gutes
gespräch mit jemandem der was davon
versteht der also nicht sofort aber
greift ja nicht so lapidare
oberflächliche ratschläge gibt sondern
einfach ein gutes gespräch mit jemandem
der etwas draus kommt die wir sagen in
der schweiz
das kann auch helfen na da siehst du was
du hier in der schweiz machst und was
ich in amerika macht finde ich ist genau
das was jetzt gesagt hast dieses
gespräch zu öffnen
zum beispiel könnte man so ein paar
sagen es ist in ordnung wenn man sich
gegenseitig zur befriedigung bringt wenn
man sich gegenseitig onaniert ohne
geschlechtsverkehr
bis heute gibt es beim blick immer noch
eine 6 beratung die psychologin carolin
fuchs weiß was die schweiz unter der
gürtellinie gerührt aufklärung heißt
jetzt sexuelle bildung
statt briefe sind es heute e mails aber
die fragen sind geblieben trotz
sexueller revolution und internet online
dating ist großes relativ aktuelles
thema waschvorgang rinne nämlich aus es
gibt die zeitgeistige thema oder
technologie knüpft thema sich sehr
verändert und die andere seite ist für
mich so die herren wo lustig ist nach
über vier jahren sechs grad immer noch
ist und das ist so sich zeigen
bin ich willkommen auf manch großer teil
von der sechs piraten einkauf und
logistik also was und liebers und
bezirks thema gott und wenn ich zum teil
frage vor dem markt leser von früheren
werden sie in der sache wo immer noch
heute mailbox oder wirklich aussieht
mailbox aber unglücklich verliebt ist
und mit weiß ja wie kann ich mich auto
oder zum beispiel einen endruck speziell
das sind alles sehr nett thema was ihr
noch fehlen vor dem out also es geht
auch die scherben von einer sehr
menschlichen haares thema wo wir alle
sind rosen das bedürfnis nach anleitung
für guten sex ist so groß wie nie
entsprechend umfangreich ist das angebot
an aufklärungs literatur für erwachsene
dies gilt platziert im hinteren teil der
buchhandlung anschauliche informationen
bietet auch das internet
[Musik]
sexualität ist bis gelernt besonders
kultivieren
ich vergleiche meine trainerkarriere
stoxx an ihr mitgefühl zum glück waschen
jemals kühler karriere passiert einfach
so sind die sexualität kann ist illusion
lustvoller sechs der celtic mit dem vom
himmel und lustigen module auch
persönlich muss immer stier rechnung
sagte barak
aber wenn ich mit dem vorschlag haben
gesprochen jetzt unterbot aber das
braucht investitionen also das buch das
lustlose aber das ist sowieso nicht für
einfach aussehen
das lied wird unglaublich volle
terminplan für mich sehr an die
strukturen hand viel zwang und wenig
ruhm und 6 % folter und denn wenn das
ist ein fall für bär total erschöpft
sind und im bett liegend aniston duscht
exportieren müssten der bayer steppe und
so funktioniert das nicht
hütz große tabus eigentlich luft betrag
wie haben deine schöne sexualität die
runde dass sexuelle bildung im moment
sehr wenig zum zug und das war so nicht
mehr im verein blickt die wünsche sogar
im kindergarten müssen kinder wissen
dass es nichts schmutziges wenn man
unten am penis oder wagen aber im privat
nicht in der klasse
auch für kinder gibt es unzählige bücher
jugendliche suchen und finden ein
immenses visuelles angebot im internet
du hast vielleicht josef hunderttausend
komische kamasutra das bios und wächst
und zwar um gut sechs euro gibt es da
verschiedene arten von 6 und wie sie zu
bestätigen und das gedruckte buch also
doch und böse sechs kilos vorspiel
nervig oder das vorspiel oder skating
ist sehr wichtig wenn es um sex video
erregt igor dies auch innenstadt und
darum geht es wenn ist und für die
vagina und das habe er mit dem vorspiel
reicher und es ist ja schon über sechs
regeln ist wirklich ein überblick sach
und die rückfahrt führt sie fällt sogar
intime beziehung als ich erzählt bahr
sage ich mich schon über alles freitag
sind total nach und mir eine gute
kommunikation
aber wenn es um sexualität gott denn ist
einfach schwierig das resi das licht in
der ersten phase ii die wünsche und
bedürfnisse gar nicht das ist der
anfangspunkt und 14 ist das einfach
sprach also sie müssen zum teil
theoretisch wie sie wieder
geschlechtsteil so eine zacke ob er denn
hand sagen ja wenn ich wenig sagen denn
ist das unromantisch oder wenig magie
nachsagen dass nach grünen kalorie
stunden quasi inland sehr wenig praxis
was räder über 86 auge porno oder
aufklärung jugendliche suchen ihre
antworten im internet
altersbeschränkungen sind leicht zu
umgehen
das wahllose anklicken von sechs seiten
im internet hat nichts mit aufklärung zu
tun im gegenteil
tatsache ist dass kinder und jugendliche
oft schon pornos gesehen haben bevor sie
erste sexuelle erfahrungen machen die
jugend heute sieht sehr viel
pornografische filme ob sie das auch in
die beziehung mit bringen das ist die
frage
denn was war in der pornografie sieht
das einmal zehn stunden eine erektion
hat vom boden bis zum bis zur decke das
ist quatsch das ist doch nur im film
und da gibt es viele probleme auch wenn
man zum beispiel zeigt dass eine frau in
diesen filmen einen orgasmus hat der
zehn minuten dauert das stimmt nicht und
das ist das problem dass man weiter gute
sexuelle erziehung braucht mit datum von
büchern von wissenschaftlichen
untersuchungen damit man sagt wir können
über diese sache sprechen und wir müssen
darüber sprechen mit dem autozug vom
storch wirklich unsere wie vor 100 oder
vor 50 jahren aufklärungsgespräche waren
und sind anspruchsvoll
im schulunterricht zu mit kondomen und
basis stil das führte bereits bringen
bei mir zu hause war das tabu sex
software um zu einer aufklärung also
schule schulkollegen vielleicht mal ein
buch etwas gelesen aber richtige
aufklärung keine die meisten
informationen eingaben internet sieht
der schulleiter nur serben war mir an
dieser schuld sexual den mix aus gesang
und mundharmonika das ist der hot stone
aber nicht was man merkt dass die kinder
man hat immer geführt wie wir sie heute
alles aber wenn es ums thema geld sind
sie irgendwie doch verloren es war ein
bisschen kompliziert darüber mit seiner
mutter zu sprechen
ich akzeptiere dass man sich ihr
wichtige infos zu dem thema wiederholt
mit ältere allgemeines gerede
messtechnik gewinnt man das nicht so im
maul ist genauso peinlich aber
wahrscheinlich
heute gibt es unzählige angebote für
sexuelle bildung nur ein beispiel sind
sogenannte mfm kurse für neun- bis
elfjährige als sperma agenten und in
zyklus chance lernen mädchen und buben
getrennt was im körper passiert und wie
sie lustvoll und wertschätzend damit
umgehen können aber nicht jede schule
kann oder will sich zusätzliche
aufklärungs kurse leisten
ziemlich fit und ich möchte jetzt gerne
erklären da ist was extrem kompliziertes
und extrem wertvolles drin ich weiß
nicht ob jemand zufällig mit dem was das
sein könnte
gabler vom vater sowie an ist was die
verbitterter und das gleich gute und
dann werden diese weg diskutieren
weiß jemand von euch wer der chef im
körper ist weil der minister hatte mir
gesagt hallo mit profis chef der ist der
chef in unserem körper penis könnte sein
ist es meistens mich nur manchmal
vielleicht es gibt es doch keine haut
es gibt noch einen der im übergeordnet
ist wer ist der wirkliche chefin wer
entscheidet was im körper so passiert wo
sitzt der der mister hypophyse sitzt
nicht im penis oder im gh ihr werdet
jetzt dann auf die reise gehen das wird
so gehen dass sie natürlich komplett
ausgerüstet sein müssen
[Musik]
permira ist timo ja diesmal bitte vor
was draufsteht über fast geschafft
gedacht und so erfolgreich beendet
bitte schön du darfst das einführen so
zum beispiel und wir haben jetzt eine
lebende eizelle sich sexualisierung in
dem sinne gibt es durch aufklärung
sicher nicht also hat inzwischen
verschiedene untersuchungen gemacht
weltweit wo nachweisen können dass
sexualaufklärung eigentlich das alter
vom es von der ersten sexualität nach
hinten verschiebt hören wir mal eben das
ist unser ansatz angeht verantwortlicher
mit der sexualität oberweis mehr drüber
gestolpert viel schneller rein
ahnungslos und das passieren sachen wenn
man nichts darüber weiß also bildung
trägt dazu bei dass man gut damit umgeht
sexualisiert nimmt sind von irgendwas
schlafende hunde wecken was aufstacheln
oder so das geht durch so eine art
vermittlung auf keinen fall
sexualisieren tun sexuelle übergriffe
zum beispiel haben kinder sexuelle
erfahrungen machen
das kann dazu führen dass sie auch
sexuelles verhalten zeigen das nennt man
sexualisieren das sexualaufklärung
sexualisiert nicht informiert dieses
essen ist noch größer geworden und auf
der oberfläche bilden sich immer noch
mehr beste freundinnen
einen tag lang lernen die kinder vor
allem eines alles was im körper passiert
ist normal
das wichtigste ist darüber bescheid zu
wissen
nach dem motto nur was man schätzt kann
man schützen
verliebtsein ein bisschen sich selber
kennen lernen entdecken und da gibt es
hat mädchen verlieben sich nicht einfach
so in einen jungen sondern vielleicht
verlieben sie sich in ein anderes
mädchen
wisst ihr wie man das doch bin ich ja
richtig was ist richtig ganz da oben hat
es nochmals etwas spezielles die
sogenannte klitoris
das ist ein ganz ganz empfindsamer
kleiner bereich und dann eben beim
empfinden bei der sexualität bei der
lust eine ganz große rolle spielt und es
lohnt sich dann noch ganz im verborgenen
ihr für royal einmal ein spiegel zu
nehmen und es ist auch immer genau zu
inspizieren
hätten wir es geschafft es ist zu ersten
periode bekommen
ich denke es ist doch applaus sie
zelebrieren die periode als ein
positives ereignis mit der periode und
so also ich finde eigentlich dass es
nicht so rosig ist normal
die jugendliche am paul busse und
vermindere im hintergrund hätte auf
inhalte katastrophen wie viel frau ich
hoffe falsches wissen und gewissen
umstand und ich bin ein verfechter info
richtigen informationen basics wie der
körper falsch interpretiert will einfach
im buch stadtmenschen 14
doch tag nachdem es fruchtbar da muss
einfach nicht stimmt dann ist man so
eine junge frau einfach schwanger
sie muss können ihre körper
individuelles und der start der app
gestartet im internet das muss sie
selber längst nicht alle schweizer
kinder können an diesen aufklärungs
kursen teilnehmen
der bund der regiert die aufgabe an
kantone diesen fehlt eine einheitliche
strategie im schulen oft die
finanziellen mittel
hinzu kommt dass konservative kreise
druck machen gegen sexuelle aufklärung
auf primarstufe 2013 auf politischem weg
eine sexual kunde für unter neunjährige
so lautet die zentrale forderung einer
heute lancierten initiative kleine
kinder müssten vor sexualkundeunterricht
geschützt werden
laut den initianten die aus den reihen
der svp fdp und cvp unterstützt werden
kommt dieser einer staatlich geförderten
sexualisierung gleich die dringend
gestoppt werden müsse
sexualerziehung sollen nicht in der
schule stattfinden sondern sache der
eltern bleiben
die initiative will diese forderung in
der schweizerischen bundesverfassung
verankern
die initiative wird zwar zurückgezogen
aber christlich konservative kreise
während sich nach wie vor dagegen gegen
werte und ansichten die ihrem weltbild
widersprechen
sie lehnen beispielsweise ab dass sex
unter schwulen und lesben als normal
gelten soll
das ist brauch es gut dass beispiel hot
nights ein lehrmittel für die oberstufe
vom bund finanziert wobei jugendliche
haben das problem heißt hot nights
also das ist jetzt dass das paar liebe
sex hätte dem open air mit johnny bin
solo und sowas von spiels dass sich
animation zur folge die luft
die moral der bedarf reduziert das
kondom tobias massiven als sie und somit
für den münster haben wir den sagen hat
sich ein neues sexualethik zählt und die
neu sexualethik das ist eigentlich die
sogenannte verhandlungsraum würde es
ganz klar ist wenn jedes also jede frau
jeder mann fritz individuen
es bestehe was was man will
es gibt es manche recht auf sexuelle
potenz und konventionen mehr
unterschritten hat das heißt es gibt
tricks vor dem vom staat kind sexuell
und wirklich dass ihre 18
die schulärztin claudia linderer besucht
mit ihrem aufklärungs koffer die
biologie klassen an der kantonsschule
wetzikon
seit elf jahren ist sie als doktor sex
an schulen unterwegs jedoch soviel frau
gehabt immer wieder und die herren schon
noch unklar ist die situation ich mache
ja geologische routineuntersuchungen und
die frage meistens deiner frau
sexualität befriedigende arbeit oder
wieder so ist das motto winterzeit hat
muss ich einen orgasmus
das ist unglaublich
also hat er sich ich finde ich die
religiöse reise aufgewachsen wo das
kastell maximum situation hinter muss
das kino kosmos hat das haben wir nicht
aber ein bisschen natur ist gehört allen
menschen als glücksfee kommunismus
kaufen und die 15-jährigen kant die
schülerinnen und schüler haben am vortag
anonym fragen aufgeschrieben mündlich
würde sich kaum jemand melden offen zum
thema sex fragen zu stellen ist wie eh
und je unangenehm
also ich aus es liegt nicht die frage
dass man möglichst durchgehend will sind
viel frage also zum beispiel jeder ab
wann sollte man zum frauenarzt wichtig
ist für uns dass turbine verschrieben
und die baby pille nur mit unbedingt zum
frauenhaus jeder auch die schweiz kommen
dann die baby pille verschrieben und was
auch ganz wichtig ist dass ihr das visit
es braucht zum anti baby pille
verschrieben kein gynäkologischen
untersuchungen
es ist aber so wenn ihr zu einem
frauenhaus kind und antibabypillen und
dann sei meistens auch okay dann sag ich
mal für die blutung step dass gott das
hätte deutschland blüht wenn ihr das
kühlende eigentlich wollte ich mich
nicht untersuchen denn sagt als ich
wollte das nicht will es ist heute die
universität meinung dass für viele
verschrieben braucht es keine untersucht
er tut nur freude als mit druckmesser
uns gleich wie viel geschlechtsverkehr
hat ein durchschnittlicher mensch pro
woche also das hin zur frage wo es
einfach keinen sinn hat irgendein
statistik oder holz haben sollen nur
mache das war jeder mensch für sich gut
findet und die ohne irgendeinen spieler
oder ich weiß etwas folge zwei mieten
und damit wieder gewitter sich also ich
habe ein angeschossener junge frau akkoc
seiten verhindert wochen einen zahn am
tag schlafen sie finde es nicht lustig
ist mittag nimmt also das miteinander
war findet dass es gut ist
ich bin komplett gezahlt empfiehlt
lustig es wohl in jedem stattfindet und
wir haben vorher sie oder net voran dass
sie wie sie die jungen und die alten
vorhanden ist und im schnitt direktor
mona panik luschkow 6 das ist überhaupt
an sexuelle knox ist wieso im kopf
passiert das kopfkino mit sexualität des
menschen kann die frau oder den mann
aufgrund von stimulation an den nippel
einen orgasmus haben oder dabei werden
trepte ja ja ja wo man sich vorstellt
danach haben sich laut stimulieren und
zum anderen in kontakt mit hinter dem
anschlag
wir sind wirklich nicht nur einfach nur
schlecht sein und machen sind
vielfältiger bitte mal die sind meistens
fdp nichts fixiert
viele haben soll bei welchen geschlechts
verorten kann die frau schwanger werden
und dann bei uns ganz genau wird einfach
das schluckt willy decker in morges oder
wird einfach alles aufgelöst
das ist überzogen momentanes freiheit
und zu schließen zuletzt machten
[Applaus]
ja also kann ich das halt vieles
verschieden ist also nicht ganz
verschiedenen finden damit hat die netze
müssten
kulturell ich bin es wichtig dass mir
zeit wisse die bedarfsliste schalters
großes thema zeit im alter
und ich finde es auch wichtig dass mir
auf weil sie sicherheit achtet und ja
einfach vorbei ja aber ich finde es
besser so will im internet statt der
ganze zwar nicht unbedingt stimmt google
hat eine die macht
je mehr weiß und kalt ist die story
basiert ein sondern machen wer weiß was
will ich natürlich nicht es kommt mir
wirklich ums emotionale 80
beziehungsweise soziale die norman
foster die geht es nun
und das heißt er braucht verantwortlich
wird ist individuum gelangt und
individuum respektive wenn sexualität im
park bleibt wird oder was auch immer
dem muss muss das paar aus handel
was jetzt etwas zurückgeht was nicht nur
gewehrt und das ist quasi wie die ethik
wo ja wohl erhöht hängt
sexuell aufgeklärt zu sein bedeutet
heute zu wissen
jeder mensch hat ein recht auf lust am
und mit dem eigenen körper unabhängig
von geschlecht alter kultur oder
religion
bitte studieren sie selbst befriedigen
ist in public key startete vision nicht
auch nicht hin auf den bergen wo jemand
dazu kommen kam aber wenn er alleine sei
besser dass man sich zur befriedigung
dass man sich selbst zur befriedigung
bringt als dass man den ganzen tag
frustriert ist laut und klar für die
schweiz
[Musik]